is there anyone well known that you
think would make a good intelligence
agent obviously they would have to start
again and and not be famous but would
you have Lex as a an agent yeah so it's
interesting there you know I have come
across a number of people who I would
say would make good Intelligence
Officers so Lex is awesome I really
enjoyed talking to Lex uh I do think
there would be a good spot for Lex in
the intelligence world I don't know that
it would be in field operations only
because Lex really believes in the
goodness of people when you believe in
the floor what what a flaw When You
Believe in the goodness of people you
can't be out there lying to people's
faces it doesn't work right like you you
have to see people as tools as
Commodities as ones and zeros like you
have to take a very cold hard stance to
all people if you're gonna go out there
and steal information from them lie to
them and trick them into false
relationships that's essentially what a
spy does
and then you get that person to exchange
information for liquor or booze or women
or money or whatever else it might be
right that's not a job for somebody who
really believes in the goodness of
people but you know on the as an analyst
taking information and being being able
to make sense out of
out of disparate conflicting information
and coming to a meaningful
probabilistically relevant conclusion I
mean that's what Lex does all day long
with robotics and with mathematics right
not to mention what value he could bring
in the world of technology and the
technology in the Science and Tech part
of CIA he could be the guy that creates
the next SR-71 so that's that's what I'm
saying there's a space for everybody at
CIA we don't realize it we're all much
closer than we really think it's just a
matter of of the psychological
evaluation and then of course being
being identified being seen being
discovered that's the hardest part
who else did you meet that you've looked
at and thought you you should really
consider a little change of career here
[Laughter]
um I'm trying to think of who else I
would know that other people would know
too so when I look at Celebrities right
Dennis Rodman would not make a good spy
it'd be really really
hard to put that guy in Disguise it'd be
really hard between the piercings and
the tattoos and it's hard to make that
guy not look like that six foot eight or
whatever he is as well yeah that's
that's tough right
um but then you have folks like Tom
Hanks Tom Hanks is like your perfect spy
like not only is the guy a great actor
but he is incredibly forgettable he's
just a forgettable white guy even as I
say Tom Hanks people might have a
picture of one character in their brain
probably the guy from Forrest Gump does
that guy look like a threat nope if
Daniel Craig walked into a room would
you notice him right away [ __ ] yes you
would notice him right away you'd either
be jealous of his good looks or you'd be
excited by his good looks or you'd be
immediately intimidated by his gigantic
frame that guy's not going to be a good
spy right same thing with Pierce Brosnan
like most of the guys out there who
would who are playing spies would not
actually make good spies
um it's not until you get to like like
Black Widow and Marvel Universe
yeah so you have you'll be familiar with
something called the halo effect or
pretty privilege basically that good
looking people seem to have better
outcomes as they go through life but not
if you want to be a covert infield
intelligence officer correct yeah if you
were to actually walk through the
hallways of CIA you would be severely
disappointed by the lack of Attractive
people
like whether you think I'm good looking
or not all right this is kind of
irrelevant I know objectively I am not a
good looking guy in American culture I
know objectively I'm not even a good
looking guy in foreign cultures because
I'm The Ambiguously Brown guy that
nobody remembers
it's it's it was a curse in high school
it was a blessing for my career right
there's a power to ugly so Call It
Whatever call it the corona effect
right the opposite of the halo effect
when all things go dark there's a
benefit there too what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]
thank you
foreign